hey what's up guys it's marquez from the
mkbhd channel back with another hd video
review and today we're going to be
taking a look at something called
fisheye lenses now what is a fisheye
lens well by definition if you want to
skip this video entirely it is an ultra
wide angle lens that can cover a
landscape view of up to 180 degrees to
demonstrate this effect we have the
canon eight millimeter to 15 millimeter
f4 lens it'll go all the way out to
eight millimeters which on crop bodies
and full frame bodies is so wide that
you can see the inside of the camera
when you're looking through the
viewfinder that is how wide eight
millimeters is eight millimeters is so
wide that you can take a picture and you
can see things that are sideways in the
frame as you look through the viewfinder
eight millimeters is so wide that i can
take a picture of the ceiling and have
the floor in the shot now i'm gonna show
you guys all this in a second but i just
want you guys to know this lens retails
about fifteen hundred dollars but you
can have it for way less maybe for a few
videos of your own uh at the link in the
description courtesy of borrowlenses.com
so the first few links in the
description will help you out with this
one now on a crop sensor dslr like the
canon t2i that i'm filming this with the
8 to 15 millimeters is times 1.6 so it's
more of a 12 to 24 millimeter so to
fully appreciate this lens we have the
canon 5d mark ii here and this is a full
frame body and you have the fisheye lens
on it already and this will get the true
8 to 15 millimeter effect so you can
rent both of these actually at the same
time from borrowed lenses.com and you'll
get in the same box so a great example
of the usefulness of this focal length
is when you can't really get far enough
away from your subject to get the whole
thing in focus like a big group shot
indoors or maybe you're taking pictures
of buildings in the city and you can't
get far away enough because there's
another building right behind you now
when you're at 15 millimeters on this
lens you're gonna get a sort of a bubble
effect but it's not exactly circular yet
you do get that sort of distortion so if
you're looking at a straight line you're
going to have it appear to be curved and
i'll show you guys the best i can in the
test shots but basically it's never
going to be a fully true representation
of the image but to get that whole
really wide angle you do need it to have
a little bit of a bubble effect and when
you zoom all the way out to eight
millimeters as you zoom out you start to
see the actual inside of the barrel of
the lens in this shot which is crazy so
it's really somewhat of a special
effects lens if you ask me i think
that's what i'd call it to take a
picture of a person with this lens you
literally have to get right up to like
the person's face with this lens so i
mean if you're taking animal photography
i don't know if you want to get up close
and personal with your subjects
this is definitely great for landscape
shots and things like that that's what i
would suggest using it for all right so
you're looking for a demo right here we
go here we go uh i'm gonna go ahead and
reach my arms out and you can see that
if i go just like that i'm get i get cut
off like at the elbows so you guys can
see we're at an equivalent of about 48
millimeters right now and boom i get cut
off so without any further ado let's
switch to the 5d mark ii which will be
in the exact same spot and i'll zoom all
the way in to 15 millimeters
so there you go this is what it looks
like at 15 millimeters and i'm going to
go ahead and do the same thing i did
again i was all white out here and he
thought that was a close-up this is a
very wide angle shot can touch the wall
and i can't get out the frame here and i
can pretty much touch the lens from here
since not that far away three feet away
from me now i'm gonna go ahead and reach
over and zoom the lens out to eight
millimeters now you guys saw this is a
curved glass lens so you're really going
to get a nearly 180 degree look at where
the camera sits in this room
now by the way you're looking at the
lens hood right here this little flower
effect thing here is a lens hood that
comes with the lid the lens you actually
get that when you get it from
borrowlenses.com but if i took the lens
hood off it'll be a complete circle and
the black parts you're seeing are
actually the inside of the barrel of the
lens so pretty crazy effect i know i'm
gonna go ahead and switch back to the
t2i now but i think you guys get the
point that it's almost impossible to get
out of the frame when there's so much in
it uh a nearly 180 degree angle now this
can also be a really sweet vlogging lens
for those of you who guys uh like to
vlog now i know it's kind of a heavy rig
but i'm walking around and this is about
a hands distance away from my face so
obviously you can get a whole lot in the
shot and give the effect that you're
holding it far away from yourself when
really when i hold far away from myself
looks more like that so i hope that demo
helped you guys out and that's basically
it for this short review of the canon 8
to 15 millimeter f4 l2 lens and if you'd
like to see some other sort of lens
review like let me know what do you want
to see your view do you want to see a 5d
mark ii review or do you want to see a
different sort of lens review or
telephoto lens or a wide angle what do
you guys want to see let me know in the
comment section below uh and if you want
to check out this lens for yourself you
can actually rent it in the description
i'll have a couple links that'll help
you guys out so thanks for watching and
more youtube tips episodes coming up
soon including a very special one that
will involve more of you guys so make
sure you give a thumbs up
as there are more many many many more
videos to come thanks for watching guys
and i'll talk to you later
peace
you